avez-vous soif de culture d'anecdotes
croustillantes comme tu es frites à la
cantine le mardi entre deux heures de
français oui mais comparation sont plus
en plus longues et c'est super chiant
les amis on est sûr vrai ou faux 2 le
design a prouvé ses j'espère qu'ils me
donnent aussi c'est parti au camp dans
les mots de passe les plus utilisés en
2016 sont à 2 3 4 5 6 2 3 6 et 9 et
qwerty oui c'est sûr chaque année la
liste des mots de passe et plus utilisés
ne change pas mettez vos placements plus
sécurisés voyant on appelle un pamfou
une cacahuète de cet homme aux faux tu
bosses délire viennent évidemment à
temps on est là pour vous aider vous aie
nobuo d'or et le nom du dieu norvégien
de l'hiver bon ok of thrones aux doors
c'est un mec qui empêche départ de
sourire mais à part ça c'est un gars qui
vient du nord
et c'est la seule info que j'ai sur lui
du coup c'est peut-être vraiment le nom
du roi norvégien du nord allez on dit
vrai avec diouf liesse c'est ouf
shakespeare portait des boucles
d'oreilles assez tendue ça ça n'est
vraiment zéro liane à laquelle
m'accrocher pour essayer de deviner
bravo qu'elle doit de la chance j'ai
envie d'y croire l'incroyable à l'époque
portait des boucles d'oreilles tête
emblématique pour la poésie [ __ ] mais
ça c'est ça que j'aime c'est reprendre
des shows et la sortir dans 10 ans me la
pète en [ __ ] je vois la [ __ ]
j'aurais jamais dû faire un tiers
philippe allaire fois je manque de me
péter la gueule mais harry potter était
le livre le plus bas ni des états unis
en 2001 et 2002 pour compagnie attention
la traduction et péter soit je comprends
pas l'anecdote la bon je dirais vrai
puisque c'est waou d'accord vend donc
c'est vraiment banni des librairies
parce que c'était un livre anti famille
occulter satanisme qui apporte un point
de vue sur la religion et qui était
violent what the fuck et c'est le livre
le plus vendu de tous les temps avec les
attends je suis très fort j'enchaîne sur
une autre anecdote à l'heure actuelle
harry potter après des livres religieux
genre le coran la bible et des livres de
citations c'est le livre le plus vendu
au monde
c'est ouf la durée de vie d'un écureuil
est d'environ 20 ans c'est assez petit
donc je dirais vrai nom c'est faux sa
vie en moyenne 9 ans ok ok tous les ours
polaires sont irlandais à c'était vrai
ça mec
ouais ouais ils descendent des ours
bruns qui vivait en irlande il ya plus
de vingt-cinq mille ans si tout débute
en irlande et puis la chine a banni le
voyage dans le temps à la télé bref ça
m'étonnerait pas je suis sûr qu'un moyen
pour une raison un peu coup comme les
mêmes raisons que le cari potter qui a
été banni à deux années 2001 2002 je
pense que oui ils font si c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai c'est génial les dramas
avec du voyage dans le temps sont très
populaires en chine donc la chine a
bloqué tous les films qui parlait de
voyage dans le temps en disant que ça
manque de respect à l'histoire a donc le
peuple qui fait un truc on le supprime
au tournoi d'aix péter d'accord je pense
aux mondiaux à spa l'histoire pourtant
je trouve ça marrant de fictivement
modifier un seul élément de l'histoire
et voir toutes les conséquences que cela
pourrait avoir sur tous les noirs que le
monde aujourd'hui serait pas du tout
pareil par exemple la laine a battu le
record du film qui a reçu le plus de
golden globes il a gagné tous les golden
globes dans lesquels il était nominé et
on l'a pas vu vous l'avez vu il ya plus
de gens qui vivent à tokyo qu'il n'ya de
gens dans tout le canada avec tokyo
c'est énorme je crois que c'est 4 5 fois
paris attend je regardais à six fois
plus d'habitants à tokyo qu'à paris mais
je pense que c'est vrai ah c'est vrai
tokyo possède plus d'habitants que la
majorité des pays tous millions
d'habitants dont 23 arrondissements et
juste arrondissement setagaya fait la
même taille que tout paris c'est un
groupe qui se passe
j'espère ne pas être le seul à meskiana
de la sorte au quel cas j'aurai la bien
qu'on les cochons sont les seuls animaux
avec les humains qui peuvent attraper
des coups de soleil à taza et hôtels
sont mille fois les gants noirs mon gars
je suis totalement droite qui fait il
n'ya pas de plage comme par exemple un
singe ou un chat ou un félin un [ __ ]
que je dirais que c'est vrai c'est faux
c'est faux beaucoup d'animaux peuvent
avoir un coup de soleil
ah c'est vraiment très fort sous
certaines conditions même les poissons
peuvent en avoir à aubusson dont ils
prennent trop cher avec les reflets tout
assez marrant ça on sait peu mais ça
n'est pas ça on apprend des trucs
incroyables squeeze apprend des choses
c'est fou en 1991 les gorilles étaient
entraînés à utiliser des téléphones par
les brésiliens c'est vrai ce témoin qui
se voit assez faux amer justement m'a
dit un truc de ouf moi [ __ ] j'me sport
à bombay l'inde possède 122 langage
majeur c'est vrai c'est tellement pays
énorme et 1599 autre longue robe
il y à milan dans une année lumière
totalement faux totalement faux j'ai
fait l'erreur en plus dans une vidéo
alors je savais déjà réponse c'est une
unité de distance et pas de temps voilà
c'est exactement ce qu'ils apprennent
sais pas peut-être que j'ai lu ça avant
de vous dire ma réponse est pas on n'est
pas à l'abri d'un mythomane l'année 2016
sous la neige les températures
enregistrées les plus chaudes c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est chaud l'empiré romain
était le plus grand empire de l'histoire
c'est vrai c'est fort c'est le 28e
attention bien ma gueule ça ça m'a bien
fait descendre sur terre on devait tous
joué à ça une fois par semaine pour rue
pour décembre
les moustiques sont plus attirés par les
couleurs claires c'est faux ils sont
aveugles il se repaît avec les odeurs
les musiques soif est attiré par les
couleurs sombres
parce que les couleurs sombres leur
servent de protection bon ben là j'avais
raison à hauteur de 1%
le bonhomme de neige le plus grand du
monde faisait 37 tête
vas-y c'est vrai vous c'est sûr et je
comprends tous ces grands voilà c'est un
mec aux usa qui a fabriqué le plus grand
du monde
la plus grosse somme d'argent dépensée
pour obtenir une vache et une vente aux
enchères est de 200 mille dollars ce
fossé plus au futur
oui c'est ça c'est 1,3 million c'est que
si elle avait la vache comment une vache
peu avant d'entendre valeur par rapport
à une autre quoi c'est bizarre le cafard
et l'animal assis jambes le plus rapide
c'est vrai je crois que sa course super
hit cette merde c'est vrai quand il est
en danger il peut parcourir 1 m en
seulement une seconde tâche avec ça
devrait vite c'est [ __ ] de merde là on
puise est répugnant extrêmement
répugnons les algorithmes de
reconnaissance faciale utilisée par
facebook sont plus performants que ceux
utilisés par le fbi a choisi j'ai envie
d'y croire
j'ai envie d'y croire c'est vrai c'est
pas choquant du tout mais bien sûr que
si what the fuck les chercheurs ont
construit une intelligence artificielle
qui est chargé d'apprendre à construire
un logiciel d'intelligence artificielle
hachey ce faire c'est vrai tu aimais
chargés d'apprendre à créer un logiciel
d'intelligence artificielle qui lui-même
cherche avec ses vacances du tout comme
ça tu as une infinité de enfin bref moi
je suis chercheur dans la main ce
chercheur le ps d'ordre sur of warcraft
et où l'alcool est le vin sont illégaux
aux us sauf s'ils sont radioactives
n'importe quoi n'importe où n'importe où
n'importe quoi là créateurs et savait
plus quoi faire je suis sûre il a coupé
toutes ces anecdotes sur un site qui
s'appelle anecdotes goal.com il arrive
au bout et là il a créé toute l'ua mais
c'est parti en couille il y a toujours
souri qui sucent le sang humain
j'ai envie d'y croire au brésil la
chauve-souris d'ici là et qu'on data
attend dernièrement une des squats de
ce2 zurich way soit détourné près le
sucès wacey date avancée delta ça marche
pas cette vingt ans quand je te fait
perdre de temps on met airbus a
d'ailleurs temps at elle a commencé à
sucer le sang des humains [ __ ] c'est
chaud une sorte de moustiques
immense qu'est bernard aka moustiques au
c ur de terminer cette vidéo est bon les
amis si en france cette vidéo je
commence à fatiguer voilà mon cerveau a
ingurgité beaucoup d'infos il faut que
je dorme pour qu'ils classent bien
toutes les infos à des endroits qui font
que je me souviendrai plus de demain
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça vous a
plu
si vous aimez les anecdotes comme ça moi
je suis un grand curieux j'adore de les
anecdotes comme ça mais un peu plus
scientifique ailleurs se voir dépasser
ou bien j'espère quand même que ça vous
a fait qui fait d'apprendre des trucs
stocks que franchement le les premières
années j'étais assez folle choses aller
vanter ou bien chaîne vidéo chat au
monde
[Musique]
ça